so let's begin ready to find out
how many fabulous scenes didn't make the
final cut of the disney live-action
cruella
the film might have a run time of two
hours but there were still things left
unsaid between the
village estella and the unruly baroness
which leaves us with the question why
were these scenes not included
let's find out anything could happen i
could throw up or i could pass out or
whatever and i would still be like
it's fine i love it
[Music]
although the film was meant to be
cruella's villain origin story emma
stone's estella
actually ended up coming out more as an
anti-hero if anything
the real villain is emma thompson's
dreadful baroness
director craig gillespie knew he had to
give disney fans as much content as
possible between the two women which is
why he sat down and planned the film
shot by shot he didn't want to film
anything that wasn't going to end up in
the final cut
this also meant that every scene they
shot was sent to the editing room to be
edited with the intent of it making it
to hollywood but while disney is the
place where dreams come true
his dream just wasn't realistic scenes
were cut from the film for a lot of
different reasons
now i'm with you um that's why you're
peeved
there were plenty of antics between the
baroness and cruella that had us on the
edge of our seats
however there was one scene where the
baroness gets snippy
that didn't make it to the big screen
craig said i think there's one scene
with the baroness where she cuts up one
of cruella's designs it's probably 45
seconds
and we lost that scene it was a moment
that would have left us questioning who
the cruel one
really was but it just didn't flow with
the rest of the film
you win some and you lose some right
how'd you like it
the baroness wasn't the only one who had
one of their moments to shine put on the
chopping block
cruella is a film composed of darkness
and humor which made it all the more
unique
however the filmmakers had to make sure
they found the perfect balance between
the two
craig said the whole process was about
how much we wanted to keep the gravity
of what's going on versus having these
punctuations for humor
unfortunately for actor paul
walterhauser this meant giving up
quite a bit of screen time paul who
played horus the close friend of estella
and then cruella is secretly a master
improviser
you just blew my mind he would add
hilarious lines to every scene he was in
however cruella wasn't exactly a comedy
which means that sometimes the comedic
relief needed to be turned into tension
craig admitted there are some jokes from
paul that i
love in the third act that just didn't
fit the tone of where we were at that
point in the film
with how funny some of his one-liners in
the final cut are
in more films than just cruella there's
no doubt these unreleased moments are
probably
hilarious phrase whatever you do don't
turn around
[Music]
however paul doesn't seem to mind a huge
amount that his lines were cut
in fact during his interview with
vulture he told them he was just
happy to be here and there's uh and
there's a lot of humor and room for
humor
[Music]
apart from deleted scenes cruella was a
film that was in development for years
before it was even known
to the public emma stone said she was
still filming la
la land back in 2015 and 2016 when she
first caught wind about the film
as you probably guessed over the years
there were plenty of modifications made
to the script according to craig
originally the dalmatians weren't
supposed to be as maniacal like we saw
in the final cut
they were only supposed to scare cruella
instead of being the reason for her
mother's demise
but craig fought for the darkness and
maybe for the first time in disney's
history
the darkness actually won it had to be
this very aggressive moment
it's one of those places where you're
going to lean in craig pitched his idea
to the executives and disney never
backed down from it once they saw it
another huge adjustment to the scripts
that diverged even from the original 101
dalmatian story
is cruella's animal cruelty situation
they knew from the beginning that
cruella making clothing out of dalmatian
fur
wasn't going to fly and their handling
of the situation
made cruella's character even more
complex than just a lady with doggy
issues
her whistle she called the dogs on her
shoes cruella plays up the image that
she does in fact harm dogs when she's
actually pretty fond of them
in the film she says sometimes it's
better to be what they expect you to be
which is a huge metaphor for how we live
in society even today
the world has no idea who the true
cruella
really is i've got a few ideas
hey disney maybe we could get some of
those deleted scenes released
all jokes aside insight on these deleted
scenes and concepts shows just how much
thought goes into what makes the final
cut of a film
it's a very intricate process especially
when dealing with characters that are so
well known already
what cut scenes would you most want to
see thanks for watching